one of the things that kills people with
cancer is cancer cachexia and that's a
highly metabolic process that destroys
skeletal muscle so then the question
becomes where are you on survivability
cancer cachexia patients do better with
protein and exercise again it is where
are you these progression are you at the
point where you're doing chemotherapy
are you at the point where you need to
protect skeletal muscle which everybody
is and how do you navigate those things
and I also think that protein does not
cause cancer or do I think that red meat
causes cancer why would this
conversation be that red meat seems to
be worse for you than smoking think
about it red meat in the in mainstream
media red meat is killing the planet
causing cancer I don't know you name it
probably red meat is responsible for the
next five things smoking doesn't